ALEX ANTHONY: I don't think
ever felt like a girl.
I grew up with
two older sisters,
and I kind of watched the
things that they like.
I was just never
into those things.
It was always like I
wanted to play football,
and I wanted to wear blue
and just wear boy clothes,
and that's always what I
felt more comfortable in.
JULIE: Alex has struggled
with his identity
definitely through
middle school.
That's when it became
pretty noticable-- just
trying to fit in.
ALEX ANTHONY: This is
when I moved to San Diego.
A boy asked me to
go to prom, and so I
had to wear a dress, which
I was not comfortable in,
and you can kind of see it.
I think this time in
my life was probably
like one of the darker times.
JULIE: He would wear a lot
of dark colored clothes.
He was definitely made
to feel that it wasn't
OK to express
himself, and I think
that brought on a lot
of sadness with him.
ALEX ANTHONY: Growing
up, my dad would say,
I know that you
want to be a boy,
but you're never
going to be a boy.
You were put on this earth to
conceive and be with a man.
-Your coffee, sir.
-Thanks, beautiful.
-You're welcome.
ALEX ANTHONY: I think
I was about 16 or 17
when I kind of figured out
what the trans community was,
and so then I YouTubed it.
Boom, all these videos pop
up, and I'm watching them,
and I'm like, whoa.
Like, I'm so excited inside
because I'm like, wow,
there's answers.
Other people feel like me.
I'm not as alone as I feel.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-So this is my fresh
idea for YouTube.
My name's Alexis, and I have
been somewhat struggling
with my gender identity,
I guess you could say.
[END PLAYBACK]
ALEX ANTHONY: It was relief
followed by that feeling
of just like depression.
It just crashed
down on my world.
How am I ever going to
evolve into this person who
I know belongs in the mirror
when I look into it, you know?
And it just kind of-- that was
when it came to like depression
and just wanting to die.
That was the worst.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-I've been watching
a of YouTube videos,
and every time I watch them I
get-- I can relate in some way
that I guess like I wish
that you could be me.
[END PLAYBACK]
ALEX ANTHONY: At the
time I had long hair,
so I'd pull it back behind my
hat and wear like two sports
bra instead of one, so
my chest would kind of
go lower and just
do things that made
me feel a little bit better.
The solutions would
all just wear off.
Every time it would
just get worse.
So then I got faced with
what are you going to do?
Cutting that first braid off,
and it felt so liberating.
I felt like so in
control of my life,
and I literally
felt like somebody
just cut the chains off me.
Like I just felt free.
JULIE: That was
like a huge deal.
Once he chopped it all off,
it was just like a new person.
ALEX ANTHONY: This
is when I really felt
like Alex was becoming real.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Some of my biggest changes
I've noticed are my hunger.
I crave like really weird
things, like steaks and burgers
all the time.
Hair on my stomach
is getting darker.
My voice is changing
a little bit.
We're just pretty excited.
How do you feel about it?
-It is different.
It's hard for me,
obviously, because I
identify as a lesbian.
I like girls, but
it just so happens
that the girl I fall in
love and that I still love
is actually a boy.
That doesn't mean that
I don't still love him.
-I have some, let's
say, 10 o'clock shadow.
I would consider it like two
o'clock shadow, actually.
[END PLAYBACK]
ALEX ANTHONY: Now we are
flying out of San Diego
to San Francisco
for my top surgery.
This is the first surgery
I've ever had in my life.
DR. THOMAS SATTERWHITE:
The type of operation
that Alex will be getting is
referred to as "top" surgery,
removing breast tissue
from both sides,
and we're taking off the nipple
and the areola as one unit,
and then resizing it and
then repositioning it.
JULIE: I feel like
after the surgery,
I'm hoping that he'll just
felt comfortable in his body
for like who he
is on the inside.
ALEX ANTHONY: I feel excited.
I feel like, I don't
know, I can't explain it.
I feel like it's real.
It's all becoming really
real and emotional.
Because this is
forever, you know?
I've been waiting a
long time for this.
I'm going to see the person
that I've been waiting
to see for my whole life.
I've imagined it
forever, and it's
going to happen in five minutes.
Hello.
NURSE: Hi.
How's it going?
ALEX ANTHONY: Good.
How are you?
NURSE: [INAUDIBLE].
Freedom!
ALEX ANTHONY: Hey,
this is crazy.
NURSE: A weight off your chest?
ALEX ANTHONY: Yeah.
NURSE: --literally.
ALEX ANTHONY: Literally.
Looks really nice.
I'm happy.
ALEX'S MOM: Wow, do you
feel like freedom right now,
or what?
ALEX ANTHONY: Yeah.
It feels really cool.
I feel like I'm in a dream,
and I'm going to wake up.
Before I had the surgery
I was still a man.
And now that I've had it,
I'm still the same person.
It's just I feel
more comfortable,
and I think that
that's something
I really want to stress because
not everybody knows that.
There's a lot of things in
my life that I'm like, wow,
I wish I would've
done that differently.
But I think this is probably
the first time in my life
that I've totally
done everything
just the way that I needed to.
INTERVIEWER: Be sure to
watch this next episode.
When you look in the mirror now,
who's the person that you see?
SUBJECT: So I see a lot
more confident person.
I see someone who'd
made a lot of progress.
And most of all, I see
someone who's on a journey.
INTERVIEWER: Thanks
for watching,
and be sure to subscribe
to "Seeker Stories."